way to overcome procrastination is to do
something harder than the hard thing
that you're putting off give me a
tactical example of this I need to write
a chapter on tools for Focus for my book
I'll do anything but that okay so then
you have to find something worse than
that so for me worse than that is
anything involving a spreadsheet just
the idea of a spreadsheet gives me hives
I would force myself to do 5 to 10
minutes of establishing a spreadsheet of
my expenses and taxes related to some
segment of my work life so doing that
you'll see it will make writing that
book chapter very accessible it's a
downhill cruise from there so we've got
do something that is harder than the
thing that you're trying to get away
from if you can do cold exposure that's
kind of cool if you're like I got to sit
down and do this I find myself for 10
minutes kind of fluffing about trying to
do stuff I go upstairs I have a cold
shower okay that was way more miserable
if you like it then no but if it's way
more miserable then that's the thing to
do